GRZELCYK.
>> ONE GOAL, NINE POINTS FORM I
THEIR OWN ZONE.ALIVE.
PLAYING IT OVER A
SAVE.
ISLANDERS TRYING TO KEEPPARISE,.
ON THE FOREHAND.
LOOK AT
CLIFTON.
CIZIKAS IS STILL THERE, PUSHING
COUPLE OF GAMES TO SETTLE
HIMSELF DOWN. UP: HE WILL TELL
20 MINUTES I AM HAPPY.
AND HE WANTS TO
WAHLSTROM, WITH A LOOK OUT, MADE
THE NOW
AND BEAUVILLIER GETS ON THE
SCORE SHEET.
THAT
CHECKER, TOP SIX OFFENSE IS PART
OF THERE IN A TRYING TO
BACK UP CE SAVE THERE.
YOU CAN SEE, LAZAPUCK.
NOW, BRUINS,
JAMS IT IN FRONT, ONE, AND LEE,
ULLMARK.UBS ARENA.E
LEFT SHOULDER OF ULLMARK.
WAHLSTROM TO LEE, NOW, THA LOOK
YOU DON'T HAVE TO.
1980.
>> Butch: THE BRUINS COME CLOSE.
CLUTTERBUCK, FILLS
GLOVE ON HIS RIGHT HAND.
TRYING TO DEFEND WITHOUTcAVOY.
LOOK HOW CLOSE THEY HE
HITS CLUTTERBUCK FOR THE EMPTY
NET AND HE
LINE.
SHOT, MIKE  ENARIO.
RIELLY GETTING TO THE OUTSIDE.D.